the nintendo switch the handheld console
hybrid that just keeps giving but it's
also got quite an expansive library so
whether you're an existing switch owner
looking to complete your collection or
maybe someone new to the switch family
looking where to start look no further
we put together a list of the 15 best
switch exclusives so let's get going
look let's just get this one out of the
way breath of the wild has been there
since the switch's launch and to this
day remains among the best of all time
for the console it's not only the zelda
game to completely rethink most of the
series conventions but equally challenge
the conventions of open world game
design and its influence can already be
seen across so many other games today
its world and its systems and how all
its elements work together is only a
breath of its brilliance now whether
you're into how it changed the zelda
formula or not there's no denying that
it is an absolute must play switch game
and yes it's on the wii youtube so it's
not exactly an exclusive to the switch
but i mean
come on come on
the one the only the italian stallion he
needs no introduction his hat on the
other hand well let's be real it's the
true star of super mario odyssey and
that is cappy super mario odyssey was
the long anticipated return to a
full-fledged 3d mario adventure with the
last one being super mario galaxy 2 back
in 2010 it's a master class on
open-ended platforming awe and charm and
is amplified with the addition of cappy
which can possess control over objects
and enemies and even add an additional
layer of platforming genius to the mix
it's inventive challenging and exploding
with personality there is no doubt that
it is among the best exclusives for the
console
you know fire emblem has really come a
long way and its popularity exploded
with three houses which took the
strategy series and sandwiched it with a
social sim fire emblem three houses
wasn't just a military story all over
but instead thrusted the player into the
role of a professor at a military
academy with a heaping load of
characters from three distinct schools
most importantly it gave you the chance
to have tea parties between your tragic
battles which honestly made losing
members of your team all the more
devastating if anything the tea parties
in and of themselves make fire emblem 3
houses a must have
while mario may be the more confident
pompous brother who gets all the glory
luigi's actually the more complex of the
two he's sensitive gentle maybe even bit
of a wimp but that doesn't stop him from
strapping on a vacuum and sucking up
some ghosts luigi's mansion 3 is a great
change of pace in nintendo's roster
first party games adding more adventure
elements puzzle solving and a hefty
serving of spooks all mixed in the game
has marvelous and rewarding level design
and is leveraged with his goopy pal
guiji which acts as another layer of
puzzle solving and cleverly serves a
means to play cooperatively with a
friend it's great spooky fun times and
luigi goes where mario don't
super smash bros has cemented itself as
a long lasting hit for nintendo making
it a mainstay for both casual and
competitive players alike and super
smash bros ultimate as its title implies
is the ultimate installment in the
series it includes every character from
every smash bros game and has been
supported by an unusually lengthy cycle
of post-launch support adding new
fighters stages and balance changes not
to mention the wealth of its music that
game is like a time capsule of
nintendo's history if you own a switch
and you don't own super smash bros well
then i think i can mend you
super mario maker for the wii u was cool
it let players try out their game
creation chops within the familiar
framework of mario the sequel though not
just expanded an already great tool set
but added a great campaign with pre-made
stages made using the game's toolkit
it's the sort of game that gives you as
much as you put in making levels is as
much of a blast as it is to play other
people's creations even if some of them
present an absolutely absurd challenge
paradise killer is kind of like if you
took the open world exploration of
breath of the wild and married it with
phoenix wright but set in a vaporwave
themed island accompanied with an
absolute amazing city pop soundtrack
it's a non-linear murder mystery set in
a fantastical world with over-the-top
personalities that's unlike anything you
have ever played and just oozes so much
charisma and coolness it's hard not to
be swooned by its originality now yes
paradise killer is also available on pc
but it's a console exclusive 2 switch oh
and did i mention the soundtrack is
amazing because um
yeah it's amazing
pokemon sword and shield is the first in
the mainline series to really lift the
franchise from its original handheld
roots and make it more dynamic in its
exploration and control thanks to the
introduction of its large expansive wild
areas where pokemon wandered freely it
also added this feature where you can
make your pokemon super big like kaiju
sized and duke it out against each other
mario rabbids kingdom battle is probably
one of the strangest mash-ups in recent
history smashing together nintendo's
mascot characters with
ubisoft's
bunnies and if that wasn't puzzling
enough it's a turn-based cover shooter
like x-com and somehow it just works
like really well so well in fact that
it's getting a sequel sparks of hope
which is expected to release in 2022
super mario 3d world was already a
fantastic game and its port from the wii
u to the switch was long overdue but
what makes it truly shine as a rightful
exclusive to the switch is bowser's fury
the inventive open world mario game that
offers a completely new and unique
structure to the mario formula you can
bank power-ups and choose your own order
of stage challenges to gather cat shines
and then engage in an all-out giant
monster brawl with bowser it's shorter
than the average mario game but it packs
a lot of fun into it that shouldn't go
missed and who knows maybe bowser's fury
will serve as the blueprint for the next
mario game that'd be pretty cool
the animal crossing series has been an
unassuming smash hit for nintendo but
new horizons for the switch exploded
upon its release in march 2020 just as
kovan 19 lockdowns were beginning and
while animal crossing was a beautiful
way to maintain socialization while
everyone was separated but even despite
the happenstance of its rather
unintentional but timely release it's
still a cozy simple game to keep you
occupied while you harvest fruits catch
bugs make friends and customize your
island
capcom hit it out of the park with
monster hunter world and thankfully
capcom took a lot of what made world
great and put it into monster hunter
rise an exclusive entry for the switch
and one that has some major quality of
life upgrades that makes ryze work
miraculously well on the hand-held
console new additions like palomute
companions and the wire bug tool make
traversal getting around cool and speedy
and honestly it's the best monster
hunter has been for handheld portability
or you know just sitting and chilling at
home too but you know
clubhouse games it's like a swiss army
knife of entertainment and in all
honesty i'd barely leave home without it
it's a collection of 51 tabletop and
card classics wrapped up beautifully in
one package we're talking chess and
blackjack and domino's in solitaire and
more it's absolutely great and has saved
many boring visits to the laundromat or
a short commute somewhere additionally a
good chunk of the games can be played
multiplayer just using one console or
multiple systems using guest pass so
that's pretty nifty
splatoon is nintendo's take on an
arena-style shooter and also
conceptually one strange game to explain
so basically you play as these squid
kids known as inklings who cover the
arena with ink and whatever team covers
the arena with the most ink by the end
of the match wins it's a simple concept
but don't be fooled the skill ceiling on
this game is high there's a large array
of different weapons each with their own
distinct advantages and strategies and
traversing through the ink alone is a
whole different story in terms of skill
and movement it's all bolstered by
special gear sub weapons and more
there's a lot to splatoon and it's a
total blast but thankfully despite that
skill ceiling it's an incredibly
approachable game that's fun for all
skill levels splatoon 2 also offers a
really solid campaign and a co-op horde
mode called salmon run which definitely
ups the ante in cooperation
okay yes mario kart 8 is one of those
games that also appeared on the wii u
but the deluxe version for the switch
gave the game a significant upgrade by
including everything added to the
post-launch wii u version including all
the extra tracks and racers like link
isabella and squid kid from splatoon
content aside it's just one of the best
racing games out there one that i've
been playing since the wii u days it's
truly never ending fun and there's a
reason why it's the switch's best
selling game so if you're watching this
there's likely a chance you already have
it but you know that's what makes it a
part of this list of best exclusives for
the switch so
yeah
the 15 definitive games that all switch
owners should consider having in their
library thanks for watching and don't
forget to give us thumbs up if you found
this video helpful oh and if you're not
already consider subscribing too to stay
up to date on everything related to
gaming alright take care folks
[Music]
you